A Libyan
intelligence operative
accused of building the bomb
that brought down Pan
Am flight one of three
nearly 34 years ago.
He is now in U.S.
custody in less than 2 hours.
He will appear in a federal cour
in Washington
to face charges for the attack
that killed 270 people on board
and on the ground.
In Lockerbie, Scotland.
Nic Robertson
has long followed this tragedy
and he joins me now.
Nic, what does this mean?
This means that the families
may get closer to justice.
This means they may get more det
about how and why the bomb was p
We know that this agent
has already confessed
to setting the timer on the bomb
to 11 hours.
They're being congratulated
at the time for the successful m
in bringing down PanAm.
103, congratulated by the Libyan
Moammar Gadhafi.
So there is an opportunity here
for a lot more discovery
almost 34
years since
the deadliest terror
attack in British history.
And the man
accused of building the bomb
that killed 270 people, mostly A
is finally going to face justice
in a U.S. court.
A huge moment for victims famili
It has been
one of our
has been the top priority
to find the truth
and hold these people accountabl
And the fact that this is now
going to happen in the U.S.
is it's it's monumental.
Libyan Abu Aguila, Mohamed Masoo
here are married.
He was arrested
for his alleged role in blowing
Pan Am Flight
103 over Lockerbie, Scotland.
38 minutes after it took off for
from London,
killing everyone on board and 11
on the ground.
The U.S.
first charged al-Marri Army
for his involvement in the attac
two years ago
while he was already in custody
for unrelated crimes.
It is alleged in the criminal co
in the indictment
that at that time
all coconspirators worked togeth
the explosive device in the suit
For years,
the only person
convicted in the Lockerbie
bombing case was Abdel
Basset Ali Mohammed al-Megrahi.
He al-Megrahi,
a former Libyan intelligence off
was accused,
along with another
Libyan man
who was acquitted
for planting the explosive
inside a portable cassette playe
in a suitcase on the plane.
al-Megrahi was sentenced to life
in prison,
but eight years
after his conviction in 2008,
he was released from a Scottish
with terminal prostate cancer.
Arriving home in Libya.
He received a hero's welcome
in 2011 following the revolution
that toppled
Libya's dictator Moammar Gadhafi
I visited al-Megrahi
at his home in Tripoli.
He was near death.
His family,
as they always had,
protesting his innocence.
Has he been able to see a doctor
You know,
there is no doctor
and has no body to ask.
And we don't have any phone line
to call anybody.
But I think that what's his situ
right now?
He's eating
and his sometimes is coming in c
Coma.
He goes unconscious. Yes.
He died the following year
without ever proving his innocen
AMORIM His trial will likely rev
of McGraw.
His defense
particularly alleged inconsisten
about how the bomb came to be
in the plane.
Now, al-Marri me
has also
known as Masood in the court
documents, has a lot of evidence
stacking up against him.
One of the questions for the cou
is this testimony that was taken
by a Libyan law enforcement agen
Ten years ago.
Is that going to be admissible i
That's a question mark.
What is unchangeable
and what is fact in evidence is
fingerprints are on a ticket stu
that placed them at the scene
when the bomb was put on that ai
This is damning evidence